can you take us back to the first time
that you pitched an investor probably
now is like in 2006 or something we're
trying to get a bigger movie off the
ground and Brad was writing some specs
for this production company that was out
of state they never produced a movie
they're just kind of investing in
scripts and we're like well maybe you
should actually you know they're you
should try to make a movie instead of
just putting so much money in
development so we knew about cool place
that was kind of like stage in the
valley that had some built in said
sci-fi looking and Brent had a concept
already for what he wanted to do there
and like a sci-fi interesting horror
movie so we went over there and we
videotaped kinda like a tour of the
place of the facility of the sets so
that together with the script was kind
of like packaged to peach kind of give
them an idea what they can get but even
that you know they like the script and
they liked the place and they got the
idea that we could do something for
lower budget but interesting but even
that took years to pry over a year to
get hold of financing as my initial
budget which was also part of the
pitching package I mean we didn't get
them as much money as we'd have liked to
initially I was budgeting for like a
35-millimeter to shoot on that longer
schedule over three weeks or something
but you know sometimes like I said what
you get you work with what you have so
based on how much they gave us I had to
reconfigure everything and shot on HD
and you know the shorter schedule then
you know but we we managed to do that
you kind of have to rethink everything
and you know have almost like a plan B
and that's our movie platers that we did
we shot in two thousand six or seven
what are some signs to an investor that
a filmmakers ready to take on you know
some people just trust you you know just
from like I don't know like you know
from like your previous work and some
people are gonna question you and
challenge you no matter your experience
and I think that you know you kind of
have to be prepared for both you know
because you never know what you're gonna
get but I think more experience you have
the better but you know when you start
out you're not gonna have so much
experience but maybe partnering yourself
with a producer or a line producer or
you know few people who have more
experience than you and you can trust to
maybe you know help you out to get
something bigger on the ground and also
help in the meeting with investors and
so on for me I felt as the woman was
always tough being in a room like I was
the only always the only woman in the
room you know from one of the country
and we're married and have an accent
so it's always he was always a challenge
to like I always had to prove myself
again and again and again even if by
that point let's say you know especially
the Quakers by that point I produce some
some features I had some of these
investors come to visit our set so they
see how we work and the way you know
they knew were completing movies were
you know on schedule on budget sometimes
with some people it could be never
enough and some people they just trust
you right away
so you know sometimes it's a matter of
luck who you meet and how they treat you
and everything I can you know everybody
has different experience but with me was
you either very easy like yeah sure okay
who is she okay fine
or like I have meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting and you know
but still hopefully at the end you'll
get the money to make the movie cuz
sometimes you meet with people and
things never happen that's a lot of time
wasting and that's why sometimes we got
fed up like that's why we made hi-8 cuz
with meetings for a couple of years to
get bigger movies of the ground and he
was economic crisis and everything and
people are very worried and even if we
made the movie that was bigger budget
and successful and everything and we got
tired of waiting and all these meetings
and things were not happening and agents
and and we're like we what do we do here
we wasting time or filmmakers we make
movies so you know who cares what magic
we have let's just take a camera and go
because this is years of your life that
you're not productive and for us that's
not acceptable but there's a big
difference between somebody identifying
someone or identifying with someone or
liking them versus someone being
competent I mean I could meet a million
people that had want to be best friends
with but they're not confident how would
you prove that you're confident that you
can deliver when you say you will cuz
sometimes you just get a feeling about
somebody and maybe they're not really
your kind of person but you're like this
person's got confident and they're gonna
come through for me and I can tell well
I think everybody has a track record you
know and sometimes your movies do speak
for yourself
you know you have your body of work and
also how I prepare you know if you see
I'm prepared and I have solutions and I
have a budget and I and all these things
that I personally bring I don't know how
other people do but I bring them from
experience and from what I've done
before you know but I you know I don't
mind answering questions obviously I
always do and I always have a plan
and for you know how I would pull that
movie off and I share it with people and
tell them how I would approach that you
know if they trust me or not I don't
know you know but um I think if you're
not prepared and that's a problem
you're not gonna have a chance if you're
prepared yeah you might have a chance
you know what sometimes we know and it's
annoying people filmmakers get money
from God knows I'm rich relative or
something they don't have to prepare for
anything like you go from meetings and
you go through a lot of proving yourself
even if you made movies and you do be
sold out in sold in different
territories and you know people made
money off your work and you can prove
that with numbers like breadhead up one
of his movies was like the best seller
of a certain distribution company they
it was a title itself so the most so I
think just that right there it's a great
at least entry if not a way to convince
somebody to give you money but some
people they'll just get monica's
whatever you know and that's something
that you kind of have to get used to in
the business that you know not
everything is fair but you just have to
do your thing
you